on the 4th chapter of the live-action
Star Wars series the Mandalorian
entitled sanctuary the series gives fans
another reason to love the popular
series when it introduced a character
named O'Mara here's why Julia Jones the
actress who plays her looks so familiar
though it's one of the actresses
lesser-known projects the Larry Bishop
directed Western tinged by Kerr opus
he'll ride is a bold entry in Julia
Jones's filmography released in 2008 and
produced by none other than Quentin
Tarantino hell ride follows Bishop and
Michael Madsen as heads of the victors
bike gang and finds them entrenched in a
bloody showdown with David Carradine
zone six six sixes game envisioned as
the greatest biker movie ever made by
Tarantino and Bishop hell ride doesn't
quite live up to those lofty ambitions
but it's every bit as violent macho and
subversively silly as its setup would
have you to believe hell rides b-movie
absurdities make for a little slice of
grindhouse heaven for cinema lovers if
you're among them you're certain to
recognize Jones for her turn as cherokee
kisum the doomed paramour of bishops
pistolero while jones doesn't play a
major role in the film her character
gets offed early in Hell rides gritty
action she makes the most of the moment
in what was just her third feature film
ensuring that cherokee kisum spirit
casts a long shadow of the film's
narrative hell ride may not have boosted
Julia Jones's profile - household name
status during the early days of her
career but it did give her enough notice
to land a role in a tentpole franchise
featuring a certain sparkly skinned
vampire 2010's The Twilight Saga eclipse
qualified as Jones's first big
mainstream break with fans around the
world taking a liking to her character
Lea Clearwater if you're here to torture
Jacob some more feel free to leave Tom
isn't she as a refresher Eclipse was the
first Twilight film to really spend some
time with the vampire hating
shape-shifting wolf folk that Bella's
bestie slash would be Bo Jacob ran
around with through much of the series
among those werewolves are Leah and Seth
Clearwater Joneses leah is extremely
powerful and was the only woman among
the wolf people to ever take the form of
the
as such she was immediately named the
second-in-command to Jacobs alpha within
the pack though there were a lot of
overarching narratives and tons of
intricate lore going on in the film all
you really need to know about Eclipse is
that Julia Jones was in it and that she
was really good in what amounted to a
relatively thankless role that she
continued to play over the course of the
final two increasingly ridiculous
Twilight flicks Breaking Dawn parts 1 &
2 luckily the rather complicated
reputation of the Twilight movies didn't
prevent Jones from moving on to better
if not bigger things in fact one of
Jones's most memorable supporting turns
came in the decidedly mid budget 2017
thriller windriver written and directed
by Taylor Sheridan windriver unfolds in
the icy vistas of Montana and sees a
troubled tracker named Corey Lambert
played by Jeremy Renner attempting to
navigate local and tribal laws while
untangling a web of mystery surrounding
the death of his friend's daughter on a
local reservation we come to find out
that the case is of particular interest
to Corey because his own daughter had
been killed in a troubling case years
earlier in hopes of providing some
answers for his old friend Corey tackles
the case head-on and stirs up some still
raging emotions within himself along the
way those emotions are never closer to
the surface as they are when Corey
visits Wilma the mother of his deceased
child and his ex-wife who is memorably
played with raw nerve energy by you
guessed it Julia Jones you got blood on
your shirt yeah I just came from work it
was the victim today though her turn as
Wilma and winDriver was short Jones
still brought some serious fire to the
mix she rendered a fully-formed
character from the abstract fragments of
Wilma and the character is every bit as
wounded and haunted by the past as Corey
as far as supporting turns go Jones's
work in Wind River isn't quite of the
legit scene stealing nature but it's
about as close as one can get the
Mandalorian is hardly Julia Jones's
first foray into television she got her
first taste of the small screen big time
with a four-episode arc as doctor kiya
Montoya on the final season of ER back
in 2008 Jones also delivered solid work
as Gabriella lengths
on a Enys Western series Longmire and
can currently be seen as Stephanie
little crow on the Billy Bob Thornton
starring legal drama Goliath
perhaps Jones's most memorable TV
appearance was as Kohana on the second
season of HBO's daring a perplexing
sci-fi Western West world as complex and
frustrating as West world season too
often was when the series took a moment
to slow down it offered wildly inventive
vividly rendered jaw-droppingly
beautiful glimpses into some of the more
intriguing corners of West world at
large
one such corner belonged to the doomed
parks indigenous people the ghost nation
and one of those astounding moments came
on the 8th episode of West world season
2 entitled kicks Ouya the episode proved
a bold narrative diversion from the
relative chaos of the season and
followed Zahn McClellan's a key cheetah
as he narrates the ghost nations rise to
consciousness he does so through the
telling of his own dramatic story a
harrowing one of a love lost and then
tragically found that story finds a key
cheetah falling passionately in love
with fellow ghost nation er Kohana only
to have her ripped away from him after
both characters are reprogrammed by the
park's storytellers as the story
progresses with the key cheetah and
kahana's lives crossing an increasingly
devastating fashion it does so with
almost no dialogue from Kohana a fact
that makes Jones's silently emotive work
in the role all the more remarkable and
that adds unimaginable way to her
reading of the episode signature line
Matan take you high yo yo you can take a
tu yo yo check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies and TV
shows are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]